no one properly told you the timing yeah
the guy was over there and he said okay
we're going to go on three and he
started going three two one I said whoa
whoa stop stop and it would stop waiting
you know we have an explosion it's going
to go in my head and he said I said
you just said on three he said well I
meant three what what does that mean
it's like now we're gonna go I said just
everyone's please it was like two in the
morning and they setting it up and
there's broken there's glass and just
tons of water and
he said well I'm gonna three two one and
I said do I go then or do I go do I go
on one like when do I go
do I go on one are you gonna push the
button is it gonna explode on one it was
you know it kind of looked at me like
I don't know
I'm not sure